so then how did you meet Ryan Gatewood
and Alessandro Tanaka it was through
this project I came in to I met with
John Hodges a 24 and he mentioned in the
meeting this this weird idea that these
guys had come to him with and I you know
I thought it sounded intriguing and it
was you know I just I was think I just
done season one of documentary now and
you know so it was in a similar vein it
felt similarly the you know sort of like
an exploration of a sort of film genre
and and also the fact that there was you
know it was foreign sat was really
appealing to me so anyway I was
interested in Isis I you know I sort of
told them I was a fan at the time I was
at SNL and doing documentary now so I
sort of I was like well it sounds great
but you know unfortunately I don't think
I can do it but yeah good luck and I
know about six months later they called
me up and said you know we still haven't
done it looks like we might be moving
ahead would you like to you know read a
script and maybe you know come in and
talk about it so I got the first episode
draft then and and read it and you know
it was funny because it's it's it was
quite different somewhat it is in what
we did but it's quite different it was
again there's a lot of action and and a
yeah a lot of jokes and you know and I
met with Brian Alex and I honestly dad
the thing I didn't have any sense of
that my experience was sort of SNL
writers who have a very particular sort
of style and tone and this was sort of
different and it kind it did take me a
minute so adjusted to to this like oh
this is like really different and
interesting so yeah I met them maybe a
few months after that and I'm really I
think what what we hit it off on was
once he actually taught to start talking
about our own favorite films and answer
what they felt influenced them and then
what I felt like we could do the show
like we sort of came together and so
realized that we had similar intent for
whole thing and and so then from there
we are the three of us sort of them
developed the this plotline for the six
episodes together and so and figure it
out which was uh yeah I was a fun
experience they again as writers are
wonderfully collaborative that you know
there was no like they were always open
to notes and always open to
conversations and it was a really fluid
process so the entire way through which
was which is great well that's yeah I
mean that was probably incredibly
important because if you're gonna then
go over to a country that I don't know
if either or any of you and visited
before right and really be fish out of
water
yeah cooing everything you would need
yeah yeah well it was also we this whole
thing sort of accelerated very quickly
so when serve I think from me meeting
them for the first time to maybe then I
went in a shot documentary now that the
second season and then a right at the
tail end of that there was suddenly a we
want to go shoot this
you know the entire series initially it
was just gonna be a pilot and there was
like no we think we're gonna a 24 which
is gonna pay for the whole six for six
episodes I'm gonna go do it when the
window is you know we got to do it
before winter hits really hard in
Romania so yes suddenly I sort of found
myself you know racing toward Romania
and then we landed there and started
prep with maybe two episodes complete
scripts if we had an outline for the
whole season but we hadn't yet so we've
really finished the scripts and so yeah
we were as we were prepping those guys
what I sort of kept them locked in a
hotel room in well I was out around
location scouting and and literally sort
of burning doing like hey I found you
know as amazing New York City back part
of this studio right you know I think
you know I think that could be the
finale episode and and it was really and
then also meeting actors we were soap
casting and you could start to cure
their anecdotes and stories about the
time period or addressing or family
members you know stories and so it was a
really cool fluid thing that we were
able to sort of keep basically
addressing and adapting and sort of
bringing those elements into the scripts
like that they weren't sort of some
sealed
you know vault of of narrative that we
couldn't touch we were able to really
keep molding it as we go in which again
crews done obviously don't love it when
you
have a finished script once you start
prep because they also need to know what
they're doing and they didn't you know
you can you can sort of reassure them
and tell them as much no no no this is
what the scenes gonna be like it's this
is it
but until they see it on paper
oftentimes they just don't believe you
for good reason because oftentimes
things change but so they're you know it
definitely stressed people out a little
bit I think the Romanians especially cuz
they weren't used to working in that way
but but I think in the end it really
helped so gives us the show as sort of a
particular Romanian flavor that we
probably couldn't have done if we just
written the entire thing before going
and you know just sort of turned it over
so yeah it was a it was a good process
in the end did you take a guide with you
or an interpreter I mean how would you
even know just some of the cult you know
some of the customs and things that to
ingratiate you to the area I mean yeah
again obviously we would you know I did
a lot of research about that time period
before goings and then but then no I
mean almost most of our crew you know
really spoke good English and so that
wasn't too much of an issue we had a
local production like a local studio
that was basically producing things for
us who are really collaborative and
helpful as well and guided us so I think
Brian's gonna magically appear next oh
that's great
you